Dylan is a biological man Joe Biden sat
down with Dylan who Dylan is now
dressing like a woman
living as a woman or something like that
um and uh Dylan asked and and I don't
even know if Dylan has had all the
surgery like Dylan might have a wang I'm
not sure
what has happened what has happened to
America
um anyway here's Dylan asking Joe Biden
if it's wrong for states to ban gender
surgeries do you think States should
have a right to ban gender affirming
health care I don't think any state or
anybody should have the right to do that
as a moral question as legal question I
just think it's wrong
okay it's an incredible response by Joe
Biden now first off I just want to say
as a general rule Joe Biden has been the
perfect presidency for this woke idiocy
because he has no idea what he's doing
he will read whatever they tell him to
read usually very poorly and he stands
for nothing right like so it's just a
matter of push this old buffoon out
there make sure that he doesn't have a
full mental breakdown in front of
everybody and then he'll just say
whatever we want him to say so when
she's can we play the clip one more time
can we play that one more time really
listen to the question and listen to the
answers the question is do the states
have a right to do this do you think
States should have a right to ban gender
affirming health care I don't think any
state or anybody should have the right
to do that
as a moral question as a legal question
I just think it's wrong
okay well just because you think
something Joe Biden even though you're
the president of the United States
doesn't make it right the states do have
a right we have states rights we have
federalism the states are allowed to
make laws and as for your morality I
don't know where your morality comes
from you often talk about your your
Catholic faith as you're pushing now for
radical eight-month abortions so whether
you're talking legally or morally Joe
you you actually have no handle on what
you're saying now again that person that
Joe was being asked the question by is a
trans woman named Dylan Mulvaney who
just recently transitioned there is a
ton of video of Dylan uh on the interweb
here's a video of Dylan the day before
two days before announcing his or her
visit to the White House it's day 222 of
being a girl I'm in Washington DC and
I'm going to the White House to speak to
the president of the United States I get
to sit down with Joe Biden and now this
news and I get to ask him a few
questions surrounding trans issues in
the United States all are obviously
wondering what I'm gonna wear to meet
the president here you go it's the trans
flag colors
cute right do you think I just knock on
the front door
let's go walking away I have been I've
been having a rough go of it lately a
lot of darkness and
and today was what I needed to keep
going
um also if you live in the U.S and can
legally vote this is going to be one of
the most important elections of our
lifetimes okay so apparently Dylan was
very depressed and then this call came
just in time it's almost as if some of
this stuff comes with some some mental
health stuff and that perhaps changing
your exterior doesn't solve all of your
interior problems but let's just put
that aside for a moment I was thinking
as I was watching this uh he or she says
that this is day 222 of being a girl I
mean it's just not reality that's just
not real and at some point we just have
to clearly State we cannot play along
with your delusions like we can